i was just back in boston to visit my
family
turns out you were we just found out
that we were in boston at the same time
we literally bumped into each other so
we ended up grabbing a bite to eat which
was very fun meal it was wonderful
yeah i had a great time seeing i ate so
much just ate
so much you ate a lot i don't know if
you can
no oh yeah he ate a lot yeah how dare
you
we just met you offered i did offer
i am presented i am a clown man feel
free but they were like
they've noticed that the shirt does not
fit but they were like don't worry
you're wearing a tie
yeah so we're fine they couldn't
fix the shirt but they can cover it up
just yeah yeah and i was at home
for thanksgiving i'm i'm a vegan i think
you know that yes
i'm a new vegan and i had to explain
that to my working-class boston parents
they didn't they didn't know what that
meant
they didn't even know how to say it my
father was just like peter
you're vegan what is that
vegan dad reagan like an alien yeah yeah
species he goes you're reagan what does
that mean burrito what's that
what does it mean i go uh it just means
you don't eat animal products
and he goes uh so what do you eat all
day freaking yogurt
you couldn't think of one non-animal
product
what does that mean beef cheek
sandwiches all the live long day
animal's dead
yogurt's not an animal
but you've met my dad you're the one
famously to him
that said he sounds like peter griffin
he does your dad sounds exactly like
peter griffin we said that last time i
was on the show and he came up to me in
his slippers in an open robe
you know dad's style
and he goes peter who's who's peta
family guy conan says i sound like
peter family guy i was like you do you
sound exactly like him
and my mother sounds like cleveland
oh that's nasty that's my mom that's
perfect my mom both of them perfect we
got to throw my mom under the bus too
you know i i oh go ahead sorry oh my dad
i want to tell you one more thing about
yeah my pop
whom i love jay holmes owner of the tank
slot company
thanks a lot like thanks a lot mm-hmm
his joke not mine
he's he's he's stubborn i think you can
you can agree we're both from
yeah he seems like yeah old men from
boston tend to be a little bit more
stubborn he's losing his hearing it's
not like severe anything but he has to
you have to repeat everything to him
twice right because he's stubborn he
won't get a hearing aid
so i noticed that this holiday season
i'd say something like uh dad mom needs
help with the groceries
like what mom needs help with the
groceries and i did that like 10 or 15
times
and then i realized like it doesn't
matter
what you say the first time
that's just to let him know that you're
talking to him
but the words are nothing so i just
started having fun with it i was like
dad i'm gonna put cinnamon on my dick
it'd be like what i'm like mom says
dinner's ready
i'm gonna be like what are we having
cinnamon dick cause he kind of heard
he kind of hurts he can kind of hear it
you got it a little oh i thought you got
cinnamon